[Music]
in neighbor drama news neighbor of drama
yeah neighbor drama submitted by Anna
banana ba ba ba da da da dadada mm-hmm
that's almost correct yeah Hilary Duff
publicly blasts her neighbor for smoking
cigarettes and weed all night
who's Hilary Duff again the Lizzie
McGuire Lizzie McGuire she's really
pretty
Nickelodeon and she's a mom now oh no oh
she yeah she's been a mantra
Nickelodeon's no it's because they're
blowing it in her [ __ ] area issues
like the pre Hannah Montana Oh Hannah
Montana of our generation but like a
more square version or something she's
saying yeah she was kind of more square
she would have like shooting out
fantasies about herself or as a cartoon
I didn't really watch the show no but I
saw a clip not too long ago I don't even
know where but it was the Hannah Montana
girl where she met Hilary Duff and she
was freaking out cuz I was right because
she like looked up to her yeah yeah so
this Meccano Montana girl Miley Cyrus
that last name I like that I like doing
shows like relate to each other is
pretty cool yeah wait wait she's a
celebrity
how would he mean neighbor like yeah but
neighbors are like wit of an acre away
from you know this is in New York man
held up and her boyfriend Matthew koma
wait his last name is coma God bail I
had to look it up like three or four
times is that coma
Oh fell with a K yeah maybe it's comma
because he always pauses his [ __ ] what
or he likes the coma he's here all right
you live in this apartment complex in
Soho words it looks like he doesn't [ __ ]
her or something his face is so bland
what is it musician huh he's a vampire
yeah I think he's some sort of musician
in the music world Polly does sad music
yeah he's a singer yeah he looks like it
so skinny malnourished like he doesn't
give a [ __ ] I'm pale yeah yeah if he's
pale he does sad stuff not romantic
stuff yeah so Duff has a six-year-old
son and they all live together in this
building here in annex yeah so then she
she posted on her Instagram stories
calling out her neighbour dieter Addison
and so I'm even named him that's his
name I know but she like oh yeah yeah
yeah hold them out like yeah even oh my
gosh a billion times on it oh don't play
the story for you here we go
that's like daxing almost neighbors
really open to any advice you have my
neighbor's milk cigarettes and weeks
never worked a day in your life must be
nice have some respect for your
neighbors who work hard
I was like rich kid yeah
what kind of a shitty apartment is it
flip 0 minutes last night because of
dieter the dick and then she posts her
his IG why are you so mean I really hope
your hangover hurts is that him this is
his profile picture but then she goes in
putting like all this cat stuff a few
times so the bullying though yeah if you
like boxing what's dog scene like when
they give up personal information online
but she didn't give out written his
address or phone number anything yeah
cuz if you have insane Paul right and in
there leveraging against someone that's
not known is that it [ __ ] hair so
that guy will get death threats for sure
he's not cyberbullying yeah so one
second let me just finish the story here
so then she says and another thing stop
breaking all your furniture when you
fight with your girlfriend or boyfriend
it scares me and my kid therapy is
cheaper I like I do like you fight with
your boy I don't worry she has to be
inclusive though cuz she can I just say
girlfriend cuz people would [ __ ] flame
her on the internet because he might
have both yeah
yeah so then to your cyberbullying thing
yeah quite possibly because he has now
it announced that he's lawyering up duh
and and then the most recent thing was
that she was saying she was saying that
Matthew her boyfriend went over to his
place and that he punched him but to
avoid his fists he hit him on the head
and he had to call the police well first
he called his lawyer and then the lawyer
said call your call the police
but then Hilary Duff's people are saying
that is absolutely false that never
happened and so now it's just like this
like neighbor war that's very public
yeah who knows can maybe like they've
already done the normal thing I'm not
hoping that they did I'm pretty sure she
didn't over confront to hate me stop
that asked twenty times that I wits and
then she's like [ __ ] I don't know what
the [ __ ] to do already tried everything
so this is my last resort that's how he
posse don't have a rule in new you can't
smoke within a weekend so he says so
deters
that the reason why he signed the lease
in that building is because it is a
smoking building mmm so has every right
to smoke then yeah and then that he also
as soon as Hilary Duff and the boyfriend
moved in they immediately started
complaining about his smoke they came in
after apparently that's different and
also why kit like if you don't like an
apartment complex that allow smoking
what I mean they're they're they're
celebrities why don't they just buy a
house in like Brooklyn or something or
Queens or somewhere that like I mean I'm
not gonna tell anyone how to live their
life but you have enough money to like
but you don't know how much money they
have cuz some celebrities they blow
money like crazy yeah she she's still
working but she's dealing with the
problem like not a rich person exactly
that was the weird part well I don't
think she actually has money cuz like
rich people would just be like this I
hate my name let's just buy the building
yeah yeah baby yeah so dieter he is the
grandson of a wealthy H dieter holter
botch who was born in Germany and
immigrated to the US and he's the owner
of wiener schnitzel no he's he started
importing lowenbrau fro beer have you
heard of it no it's this beer that looks
delicious
oh that's big in Germany yeah so it's
one of the top beers in Germany actually
yes so his grandfather's started
importing that beard to the US and then
he just made a ton of money and so
that's why Hilary Duff is saying like
yeah we know your parents pay for your
place but then dieter saying he's saying
like no I work three jobs no you don't
we dealer I'm a reed grower and the weed
smoke I don't know we fertilizer listen
man like if you're gonna lie about what
you do you can't go that ham dude yeah
you should have just had one job I mean
it's three jobs he's an actor he's a
photographer I needs a [ __ ] graphic
designer that's what he goes
what are the jobs dear the jobs like he
says he does is he works he works at his
family's real estate office and he's an
event producer who who manages music
artists okay so these are not jobs on
the job yet that's what he says I was a
watcard
and that's three of them I was three
cars [ __ ] trust fund kids want to
prove that they're actually like doing
work my parents office would time and I
filed the paper I work at their office
this Mook straight-up reminds me of like
my adult cousin that said he had new
year's goals and he showed me what his
goals were and it was take out the trash
do the laundry it was a [ __ ] to-do
list I thought you were an idiot that's
a goal that's all [ __ ] lazy here
that's what he thought New Year's goals
are it was just a daily to-do list
it's like minus three it's the event
producer and manages artists those are
separate okay anyway yeah so that's the
whole drama going on with Hilary Duff
right now the whole I guess it's just so
unselecting like rich it's not rich dude
you got it man to be rich
well the thing is it's [ __ ] they sound
like they're living a rich building
there's also like this unwritten law I
think if you're the newcomer to this
community then there's gonna be like a
culture there like everywhere you live
like whether it's a neighborhood or
whatever and then you can't impose like
whatever you want on the on the locals
but that had this happens like in Hawaii
this happens in little towns like we're
like you know people from California
just [ __ ] move into like a small town
in Texas or whatever right and they they
have their California ways but they have
their Texas ways they might be like into
soup like smoking ribs or whatever and
they're like hey it's getting in my
[ __ ] house and this [ __ ] happens in
Hawaii too like Californians move in and
they have they're like you know I'm so
used to [ __ ] calling the cops on you
[ __ ] instead of just talking things out
or whatever and this is the same thing
in an apartment complex
it's like if it's a smoke and everyone
like smokes smokes weed and you're the
party pooper but you're the newcomer you
look at the [ __ ] out of there ya didn't
even mentioned that he offered to have
his own contractors going to Hilary
Duff's place to check out the
ventilation system because obviously but
then he's saying that the he first had
to ask permission to the building
managers and then they never got back to
him so he's like at least I tried but
this is all like well in my mind is just
like if you're choosing to live in an
apartment complex and I bet everyone
here has lived in an apartment complex
you know what you're getting into like
your choose you know that you have to
deal with close neighbors that are
sharing walls that are like you know
that that's what you're getting into
yeah so to like yeah you can complain
about your neighbors but like if you
have that much audience and you're just
like listing their name and like that's
crazy there it's not smart it's just
it's kind of mean I only do that if I
want to destroy someone yeah you could
also be that they live in such a ballin
apartment complex that for them like if
you don't cater to me then one of my
paying all this for but he's playing
paying for the same wall yeah he is
paying for the same law yeah and now
he's saying that he's receiving death
threats from all her family places that
now he has to hire a bodyguard could be
afraid you know it's weird to me is that
so this is supposed to be a plumber full
of ballers right like he's he's from all
money she's like a celebrity why the
[ __ ] does it sound so raggedy like they
live in a roach motel
ratchet [ __ ] right yeah like the
ventilation system is so bad I don't
smell any of my [ __ ] neighbors I'm
not even in a rich ass place like them
we used to smell it but I never went in
a room it was hella weedy
our hallways were like it was like I
think to agree because there was a music
studio like two two doors down
and so they smoked and he was right next
door was that right at start and there's
another one was like a room full of
college students oh they smoke weed all
the time so as soon as you come out of
the elevator and their parents are rich
like [ __ ] I think they're all SC
students or whatever but then at least
when we went into our apartment
it was nice and clear so that was cool
in van nuys I live in an apartment where
you could smell the cigarette smoke
through one of the cupboards in the
kitchen like it would like for some
reason seep through there but like at
the same time I can't tell my neighbor
to stop smoking it's his apartment too
like you could only complain to the
building right exactly that's why I
don't think it's really fair to just out
your neighbor on social media [ __ ]
fine with no face she knows where she
just jump them later or something else
no especially if it's a if it's not a
non-smoking apartment if it's if smoking
is allowed if it's non-smoking then you
could tell on them yeah cuz I think I
feel it's kind of like imagine I go to a
apartment and they're saying like this
is cats or okay and then me being
allergic to cats
yeah I'm moving into this place but I
think if I really still wanted to live
there I should do my due diligence and
asked it like ask the the person that's
showing me hey does this person have a
cat next door what about this person to
have a cat versus me moving in and all
this [ __ ] cat dander is going into my
apartment like and then you complaining
and telling the person to get rid of you
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] up I want to
hear the full story I want to hear it I
want to be the judge
[Music]